hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John this is Roca I am told John wrote
it movie clips take it we're gonna watch
the whole day yikes
oh it's probably gonna be the sewer
scene no it's the sex scene there's no
way that's in the movie you guys can
check out the Roca nadir at the outlaw
nation a show I'm suppose no and top ten
he also has cinephiles podcast Roca says
on social media our Schmo down match up
this week on Collider videos okay
mr. Roker yes I don't think we're gonna
go down I ever done many pushups in
prepper is the most important quality to
winning a Schmo down I broke a brick
with my face Oh will it be some kickin
in this match definitely yeah oh wow
nice very good John I'm very very good
all right let's check this house
president John Humphrey almost you know
that should be the name there's a
right when will I get more paper not my
paper [ __ ] [ __ ] you hi Georgie oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
Oh
child oh I remember the it miniseries
that kid gets his arm ripped off yep
right away no no no I and I'm looking
forward to that that sunset Jesus Christ
that's scary man that was a cool clip
because we really got to get a good look
at how Pennywise sounds and behaves yeah
acts that's intact I really do like the
end talks we should be going to the
category sound now everyone's gonna be
trying to do this voice Tim Curry's
voice and his whole presence was so
memorable yeah easily the most memorable
part of the miniseries but and when you
get cast to do this role I kind of think
of like when Heath Ledger's cast for the
Joker and he's thinking of like Jack
Nicholson in the back yeah yeah I'm sure
that he had was his Peter scar scar
who's the actor will yeah it's the
brother one of the Salamanders yeah yeah
do you see atomic blonde yeah yes the
guy that was helping her out the atomic
black-eye he's German because the one
guy who like helps him yeah one dude I
really liked what he did because Tim
carries is so memorable but I feel like
for a film for map or something that we
want to take more serious the miniseries
rather can't be him Curry's very
over-the-top and he's not that over the
top here you know hey being like a clown
but it's a much more sinister quieter
performance yeah I'm really intrigued by
what he's gonna do that was really
creepy it's scary as hell I mean when
he's like thinking when it was someone
hits their T's I was gonna get away from
me it's unsettling with a certain
enunciation he had yeah yeah that's
scary is that was the long front teeth
yeah oh yeah well I'm like then he still
sounds like a smoker just a different
kind of yeah cuz he does have that like
there is a grit and a gravel and there's
something icky in the damper of his
voice but it's not that same leg I
enjoyed yeah not the same Tim Kerr
intonation so like I I do appreciate it
seems like he's making it his own and
weirdly in and this is takes place in
the 80s when I saw the in miniseries I
was like come on a kid wouldn't fall for
like I I you Georgie like this that kind
of do
it's like but for something like this I
feel like a kid could possibly fall
right for that yeah cuz he's creepy but
he's still there like the right amount
of like oh maybe he's good knee I don't
know he's smiling my almighty voice
creepy child like oh yeah well it wasn't
the film like oh the TV series wasn't
that set in the 50s when they were kids
maybe they would accept a guy like that
yeah come in a kid come in because
that's not yeah dude you bought cherry
coke exactly the book takes place to the
kid their kids in the 50s and they
become older in the 80s when it comes
back now they're doing their setting in
the 80s so it's the 2010s with the
second film for the second good club
basically this movie takes place at the
same time as stranger things and
Pennywise there's something to do with
yeah exactly
Pennywise created the upside yeah pretty
much well I'm excited for it I mean that
seemed out aspiring I can't tell you how
many girls I've picked up that way hey
oh yeah nobody expects to look down
there you know like hey that's a great
way to start a conversation that's right
is something you need yeah well yay
don't look down there hello hello that's
my clown what I call him Pennywise yeah
you call your penis Pennywise Oh sad
legs you know somebody well subscribe
yay exists yes dad John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram yeah Rochus says
on the socials of media's outlaw nation
top-10 on schmoes no cinephiles is the
podcast he's part of Collider videos as
well Snowdown match coming up ah ah
promotion promotion promotion